- Just for the record, there's
not one person in this group
that I would have chosen
for this type of mission.
They're all too reckless.
(dramatic music)
(somber music)
- The government has killed
hundreds of families.
(woman screaming)
Many more will die if
something is not done.
- What do you know about
what's happening in Ethiopia?
- It's another bloody genocide
and nobody gives a shit
because it's in Africa.
- Well, your prime minister
decided to give a shit.
(beating music)
The Red Sea Diving Resort.
It's a hotel we could use
to smuggle the refugees
through Sudan to Israel.
(airplane engine roaring)
- So, let's be very clear.
(beating music)
If this goes wrong, you'll
all be hanging from cranes.
(beating music)
- [Man] Mesu?
- Best cover we could ask for.
(dramatic music)
- Ace is on the way home.
- There are still hundreds
crossing the border every week.
(somber music)
- It's gonna all right.
- [Soldier] We are watching you.
(car engine revving)
- If you ask me, this entire
country is a tinderbox.
- The mission isn't
over for us, I promise.
- This is not a mission for me.
This is my life.
(gun cocking)
- They're executing
dissidents, it's revolution.
- We must leave now.
(dramatic music)
- They're dying.
And they're sick,
and they're starving.
(dramatic music)
- [Man] Is it a roadblock?
- Full speed ahead.
- You are crazy.
- You're a lucky guy.
But when the luck runs
out, you gotta have a plan
and you never have one.
(dramatic music)
- We will leave no one behind.
(man yelling)
- [Woman] We're all
just refugees aren't we?
(dramatic music)
(somber music)